DC's Deathstroke has enjoyed a resurgence
the past few years thanks in large part to
the CW's Arrow.
As we settle in for Joe Manganiello's version
of the character in the DC Extended Universe,
we're taking a deep dive into the character
and offering a few tidbits you might not know
about one of DC Comics' greatest tacticians
and most dangerous villains.
Here's the untold truth of Deathstroke.
Original Terminator
Though he's likely best known for his more
recent work, especially his roles on Arrow
and the upcoming Batman film, Deathstroke
has been causing trouble in the comics for
almost 40 years.
Slade Wilson was first introduced in New Teen
Titans #2, which was released in December
1980.
At the time, he was known as Deathstroke:
the Terminator.
His first appearance came four years before
James Cameron's Terminator, but by the mid-'80s,
most people associated the name with a time-traveling
Arnold Schwarzenegger, regardless of who came
first.
DC opted to quietly retire the "Terminator"
subtitle and just stick with Deathstroke.
In the years since, he's taken shots at just
about every DC hero in the books.
For example...
He beat up the Justice League
The Justice League may be DC's Mightiest Heroes,
but they still need to watch out for Deathstroke.
As part of DC's Identity Crisis storyline
in 2004, Slade was employed as the bodyguard
for Doctor Light.
Since that involved protecting him from a
large contingent of the Justice League, Deathstroke
strategized how to take down each separate
member, and systematically started neutralizing
them.
He faced off against a team comprised of the
Green Lantern, the Flash, Green Arrow, Atom,
Hawkman, Zatanna, Elongated Man, and Black
Canary.
It was working pretty well...until Green Arrow
jammed an arrow through his eye and sent him
into a blind rage.
At that point, he just started pounding on
Green Arrow, which gave the rest of the team
an opening to tackle him to the ground and
stop the fight.
So close, Slade.
So close.
He defeated the X-Men
In times past, DC and Marvel weren't afraid
to crossover for some truly insane—and fun—comics
events.
Deathstroke got his chance to prowl around
the Marvel Comics universe as part of Marvel
and DC's The Uncanny X-Men and The New Teen
Titans one-off, which found the Titans and
X-Men teaming up to stop Darkseid.
But the Titans brought along their most famous
nemesis for the ride, who took out both the
Titans and the X-Men along the way.
Not even Wolverine and Colossus could defeat
him when the battle started.
It just proved again that he's a force to
be reckoned with—no matter what comics universe
he's in.
He inspired Deadpool
You don't have to look much further than their
names, skill sets, and outfits to realize
that Deathstroke and Deadpool have maybe a
few things in common.
Well, there's a good reason for that: Deadpool
is basically an homage to Deathstroke, just
with more of an attitude.
"I know, right?"
Deadpool co-creators Fabian Nicieza and Rob
Liefeld were reportedly big fans of Deathstroke,
so they borrowed from their fan favorite when
putting together the pitch for Wade Wilson.
In fairness, the characters diverged quite
a lot once Deadpool's story developed.
Liefeld said:
"While ruthless, there is certain nobility
to Slade.
He tried to have a normal family at one point,
and believed in honor amongst thieves.
Wade, while canny, is an insane person.
The similarities are they both shoot guns
and wield swords."
Family ties
Unlike a lot of comic book villains, Slade
Wilson is also a family man—and his family
has also crossed paths with the Teen Titans
several times.
In almost every case, it didn't go well.
His son Grant cut a deal with the evil H.I.V.E.
for enhanced abilities to take out the young
heroes, but the enhancements taxed Grant's
body too much, and he died in his father's
arms.
Slade's second son, Joseph, was kidnapped
and had his throat slit while Deathstroke
was trying to rescue him.
Joseph survived, but the injury severed his
vocal cords, leaving him unable to speak.
Slade's wife, upset over the whole ordeal,
shot him in the face and damaged his eye.
And that's not all: his daughter Rose became
a villain under the adopted mantle Ravager.
Guess villainy just runs in the Wilson family.
Hail to the chief
An alternate version of Deathstroke is introduced
in DC's animated film Justice League: Crisis
on Two Earths.
In this world, Slade has gone into politics
and climbed the ladder to become the President
of the United States.
Unsurprisingly, the guy's a pretty badass
POTUS, leading U.S. forces alongside the Justice
League to battle the Syndicate.
Interestingly, this Slade has an eyepatch
on his left eye instead of the right, since
he's sort of a mirror version in this world.
Not that it matters.
Eyepatches are always cool.
"You can't see it.
I just winked."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!